so earlier this week Albert Greer of
si.com reported that the Patriots are
sniffing around the trade market for
receiver and tight end and Peter Criss
and I talked about this yesterday I mean
is this an effort to try to convince Tom
Brady to stay or is this an effort to
prepare for life without Tom Brady
either way their collection of receivers
and tight ends isn't good enough they
have no one who commands double coverage
down the field they do not have a a deep
roster of guys that you can count on to
catch the football if you throw it in
their direction
what do you think they're preparing for
is this the pitch to keep Brady or is
this hey if he goes we really need
better receivers it's the pitch to keep
Brady because think of it this way Mike
if Tom Brady stays he's going to have to
know that the New England Patriots are
into in for what he would be in for
which is to win now and when they picked
in kiel Harry they had no idea that it
was going to be basically a redshirt
year right you know that that and that's
what it became for this team and so to
me if you go into free agency this year
and you're bringing Brady back you have
to do everything you can to get Emmanuel
Sanders you've got to do everything you
can to get either Eric Ebron or or or
Austin Hooper or or Hunter Henry you
know and to me I still look at this and
Mike if you noticed when the
compensatory picks came down yesterday
the New England Patriots now added two
additional picks at the end of the third
round so now they're sitting there with
87 98 and 100 as well as their
first-round pick yeah they don't have a
second-round pick but they are in
position easily if they want to to be
able to move around and get and I'm just
gonna use this name because I always do
a Terry Maclaurin type Terry Maclaurin
last year the 76 pick in the draft with
Washington if he had a great quarterback
situation there he easily could have
been
were Offensive Rookie of the Year in the
NFL and to me when the New England
Patriots you know they could move around
in the 70s or 80s and get a really good
developmental wide-receiver long term
but if if they bring Brady back there's
gonna be more pressure on them and
Belichick understands that they can't
get a potentially developmental receiver
who doesn't produce right away the way
in kiel Harry was last year so if Brady
comes back I say they go veterans if
Brady doesn't go back they go young guys
yeah I don't disagree with any of your
thoughts there you know I will say this
of course they have to improve what they
got there no matter who's the
quarterback but certainly if Tom Brady
and they want to make it enticing and
make another run at this they got to
improve a little bit now
hey I expect him kill Harry to be a year
better right you know Julian Edelman
still gonna be Julian Edelman Jacoby
Myers it was another guy that was young
the course I think he'll be a little bit
better but you know in Mohamed Sanu we
know he had an injury he'll be he should
be better you're too in that system as
well but they do need a difference-maker
and I'm with you Peter more of they need
to go something I think right now
especially in Brady in his last year of
the proven route you got to go I think
that way I think you're you know if
you're putting too many chips into who
will find the guy in the draft it's just
too risky and I would say this to you
know if Brady stays I do think they're
gonna be aggressive whether it's a trade
and free agency or whatever it may be
but I don't know if they'll be as
aggressive as he leaves if he leaves I
think they'll get really aggressive
because there are two reasons one I
think balichek's didn't want to show he
can win and the offense can still be
good with Brady but two I think you'll
need the star player on the offense
because Tom Brady and the luxury of him
knowing every pie in the history of the
New England you know offense and being
able to have that a disposal that'll be
gone there'll be a little schematic
advantage gone for New England in that
aspect where they're gonna need the
pliers to make some plays and I can
envision that happening - there's always
been this quirk with Brady that he's
very slow to trust receivers as well
which which makes it less likely that
they would go
bringing a bunch of rookies who are
wet-behind-the-ears and trying to learn
the ropes in the NFL and and it really
makes me think that and this and again
I'm rooting for Tom Brady to leave just
because I'm rooting for chaos but if
he's gonna have to break in with a new
bunch of guys anyway he may as well go
somewhere else Julian Edelman is the
only one that he's got that connection
with and it takes him years to develop
it and he's got no one else Gronk is
gone and other guys he'd be comfortable
with her gone and if he's gonna be
uncomfortable anyway with his past
catchers
he may as well be uncomfortable with a
new team
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports